herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
sternstunde philosophie hinter plexiglas
wänden in einer zeit die uns alle
gefordert wir erleben die größte
mobilmachung seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
aber auch das größte wirtschaftliche
hilfspaket unserer geschichte was
bedeutet das für unsere demokratie
wie viel freiheit darf uns der staat
nehmen und welche politischen kräfte
profitieren von dieser ausnahmesituation
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit karen horn
sie lehrt ökonomische ideengeschichte an
der universität erfurt und kommentiert
das zeitgeschehen oft im zoo der nz
und ich spreche mit roger de weck er ist
ökonom und publizist und gastprofessor
am college of europe in brügge ganz
herzlich willkommen schon sind sie da ja
ich möchte gerne bevor wir loslegen doch
eine persönliche frage stellen nämlich
wie es ihnen eigentlich so geht in
dieser krise in der wir ja alle
anfängerinnen und anfänger sind frauen
persönlich geht es mir gut ich kann aber
nicht leugnen dass mir die ganze
situation natürlich sehr unheimlich ist
und sehr große sorgen bereitet also ich
fühle mich in denen sich gar nicht wohl
ohne im alltag jetzt mich besonders
eingeschränkt zu fühlen aber
grundsätzlich bleibe ich optimistisch
dass wir das schon hinbekommen und dass
es gut weitergeht was macht ihnen denn
am meisten sorgen
wir machen natürlich die zunehmenden
krankheitsfälle sorgen das ist schon
etwas was wir so noch nicht erlebt haben
und natürlich der allgemeine stillstand
von allem
man spricht immer von der wirtschaft
aber steht ja auch alles andere still
und das wird schon etwas mit unseren
gesellschaften machen wenigstens stehen
die sternstunde nicht still
es gibt plötzlich in unserem leben etwas
was es noch nie gab und weil jeder
zuschauer in jedem zuschauer bei uns
hier am tisch ist plötzlich neue lage
und das ist das eine und das noch
dramatischere finde ich ist
es gibt abertausende tote quer durch die
welt und es wird noch viel mehr tote
geben
denken sie an die ausbreitung des virus
in der dritten welt wo die
gesundheitssysteme noch viel weniger
leistungsfähig sind als bei uns und auch
bei uns sind sie vielerorts bereits über
fördert also es kommt auf die gesamte
welt eine katastrophe zu und selbst wenn
es einem rückzugsort den mann dann hat
einigermaßen gut geht
der kopf der ist besitzt der kopf der
ist besetzt und wir stellen auch fest
stark im moment ist nicht das individuum
vielleicht in seinen sozialen
beziehungen aber insgesamt ist das in
jedem nicht stark auch das volk ist
nicht stark sondern wirklich stark ist
der staat seit der bundesrat die
außerordentliche lage verkündet hat
regiert der eigentlich im alleingang das
parlament konnte nicht tagen erst beim
vierten mal bis zu einer sondersitzung
kommen auch der föderalismus ist
ausgesetzt und in dieser zeit erscheint
ihr buch roger de weck mit dem titel die
kraft der demokratie wie kräftig ist
denn die demokratie in diesen stresstest
ich vermute dass die guten demokratien
noch besser werden nach der krise und
die schlechten noch schlechter man sieht
dein entwickler opfern der ungarische
ministerpräsident und der hat gleichsam
eine corona diktatur bereits errichtet
auch wenn die ungarinnen und ungarn auch
die europäische union das wahrscheinlich
nicht sehr lange dulden werden
die verfassungen liberaler demokratien
die sehen alle vor dass der staat
drastische massnahmen treffen kann
im unglücksfall im katastrophenfall und
das ist wichtig und die staaten die zu
wenig tun wie zum beispiel die usa wie
anfangs großbritannien die werden ihre
demokratie beschädigen mit anderen
worten die weitgehenden maßnahmen die
wir jetzt haben betrachte ich nicht als
undemokratisch
aber die politikerinnen und politiker
müssen wissen sie werden genau
beobachtet und nach der krise müssen sie
rechenschaft ablegen was war vor der
krise gut vorbereitet worden was weniger
gut was ist in der krise richtig und
falsch gemacht worden welche lehren
zieht man dann danach das ist
demokratische rechenschaftspflicht und
da sind wir die bürgerinnen und bürger
wichtiger denn je
aber diese verschärfungen die gerade in
vielen staaten passieren in autoritären
staaten passieren gehen eben die
verschiedenen regierungen versuchen
diese krise zu nutzen um ihre macht noch
mehr auszubauen
darüber möchte ich gleich noch sprechen
wenn wir noch kurz bei unserem staat
bleiben frau horn
sie sind ja auch eine liberale publizist
in eine person die immer wieder sich
auch dazu äußert wie viel der staat
eigentlich darf und sie schreiben in
einem aufsatz in diesem buch hier zum
thema freiheit der aufsatz heißt die
büchse der libertas beschreiben sie
staatliche steuerung damit sollten wir
es nicht übertreiben
denken sie auch jetzt in der krise noch
so in dem aufsatz den sie zitieren mache
ich ein bisschen was anderes als dass
wir das jetzt klingt ich versuche zu
zeigen dass eben die reine fixierung
viele liberale nur auf die wirtschaft
und den markt nicht reicht sondern dass
die demokratie dazu gehört dass das zwei
elemente unserer unserer
gesellschaftlichen koordination sind die
zusammengehören und die untrennbar sind
das bedeutet aber eben auch nicht
gleichzeitig dass über die demokratie
und das politische wird zu weit gehen
sollten in der in der feinsteuerung das
ist sozusagen der kleine nach satz den
ich gerne mache und an dem würde ich
auch heute noch festhalten
der staat ist in dieser situation
natürlich gefragt und ich würde ihn auch
nicht zum volk in opposition setzen
sondern der erfolg ist in einem
demokratischen land ja legitimiert ich
weiß nicht wirklich jetzt den satz
richtig angefangen habe das ist der
stadt legitimiert durch das volk in
einer demokratie und insofern sollte das
nicht gegeneinander gestellt werden die
steuerung zu weit treiben wurde bedeuten
wenn wir heute in dieser
ausnahmesituation regeln
verabschieden die kein verfallsdatum
haben die also unsere verfassung ändern
die unseren demokratischen verfahren
ändern
die uns in einem ganz anderen land
politisch wieder aufwachen lassen würden
als in dem wir heute sind
und das sehe ich nicht dass das passiert
und das ist gut aber genau das wäre das
wovor ich auch heute nach wie vor warnen
würde
wir werden wenn diese krise langsam
abebbt mehr der nähe brauchen das wir
märkte haben die einigermaßen
funktionieren damit wir wirtschaftlich
wieder auf die beine kommen wir werden
es brauchen dass die zivilgesellschaft
funktioniert und dass sie sich
einbringen kann und nicht völlig
ausgeschaltet ist all diese dinge darf
der staat jetzt nicht den spontanen
kräften wegnehmen wenn wir denn wieder
auf die beine kommen wollen das halte
ich sehe jetzt wenn sie sollen
vielleicht sogar noch wichtiger als
schon im normalfall
da bin ich einverstanden mit einem etwas
anderen rückblick wir sind in einer so
widersprüchlichen situation allesamt im
home office oder zu hause und von zu
hause aus sehen wir wie die
allgemeinheit immer wichtiger wird das
öffentliche wir sind auf solidarität
angewiesen so viele menschen brauchen
schlicht und einfach andere menschen die
beispielsweise für sie einkaufen und und
und und ich glaube dass diese krise eine
chance ist die allgemeinheit das
öffentliche das gemeinsame das
gemeinwesen wiederzuentdecken und da
sollten wir nicht vergessen dass vor der
krise beispielsweise systematisch in
halb europa und auch woanders auf der
welt die gesundheits infrastrukturen
heruntergefahren worden
in deutschland wurden 50.000 menschen
pflegepersonal nach und nach abgebaut
über die vergangenen jahre
und das war durchaus auch eine folge
dieser sparpolitik die wir vor der krise
hatten
und sie trifft natürlich länder die
massiv sparen mussten wie italien
spanien die ihre
gesundheitsinfrastruktur aber
radikal vermindern mussten umso heftiger
und sie trifft länder die von vornherein
keine große allgemeinheit haben wollten
die usa deren gesundheitswesen in
jämmerlichem zustand ist wohingegen
während derselben zeit der amazon
gründer jeff bezos 150 milliarden dollar
anhäufen konnte obwohl er jahrelang in
usa praktisch keine steuern zahlte ich
glaube bei aller solidarität die wir
jetzt haben müssen wir auch sehen es gab
krasse fehlentwicklungen vor der krise
die diese krise jetzt in manchem land
verschärfen man muss natürlich auch ein
sich fragen ob dieses sozusagen die
solidarität feiern wie sich jetzt gerade
gemacht haben ob das auch irgendwann zu
spannungen führen könnte weil man zu
viel solidarität erwartet also ich weiß
schon worauf sie hinauswollen hätte weg
sie betonen ja auch immer wieder in
bezugnahme auf montes kür zum beispiel
den französischen philosophen dass jedes
jedes staatswesen jede gesellschaft
einen esprit general braucht einen eine
eine gemeinschaft die zueinander hält
und das könnten wir gerade wieder ein
üben
zugleich sehen wir dass zb vielleicht
generationenkonflikte wieder neu
aufflammen könnten weil zum beispiel
junge startups im moment natürlich
bluten und sich fragen wie lange solche
krise gehen wie lange müssen die
rücksicht nehmen auf die ältere
generation
es wird nach der krise sehr sehr wichtig
sein dass der gelebte gerechtigkeit ist
das wird von dem corona
wirtschaftseinbruch so viele
verliererinnen und verlierer geben
und wenn die im stich gelassen werden
und wenn die fast schon zur finanzierung
dieses wirtschaftseinbruchs
herbeigezogen werden dann gibt es
ungeheuer ressentiments und gerade auch
was sie sagten möglicherweise beim
ausklingen der krise werden die älteren
menschen länger soziale distanz üben
müssen weil sie zur risikogruppe gehören
und weil sie hier nicht respekt ernten
wenn sie nicht einbezogen werden wenn
die gesellschaft ihnen nicht solidarität
bekundet genauso wie
den jungen start up unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern dann weckt das auch ganz
große ressentiments
nein diese krise wird ungeheuer viel
geld kosten
und dieses geld lässt sich schlicht und
einfach nicht finanzieren durch die
opfer der krise diejenigen die heute
besonders viel geld anhäufen konnten in
den jahrzehnten davor und die
vermögensverteilung ist ja unglaublich
und läuft gleichgewichtig geworden
die werden solidarität üben müssen es
gibt schon viele amerikanische
milliardäre denen ihr super reichtum
unheimlich geworden ist und die sagen
dem künftigen amerikanischen präsidenten
bitte erhöht die steuern auf die reichen
so was nach der krise wird brauchen sind
sie so optimistisch dass es dann
plötzlich steuererhöhungen geben wird
vielleicht ist es für sie wackeln ich
bin optimismus verbunden frauen eine
höhere staatsquote das würden dann alles
sehen was dann die die notwendigen
mittel sind um finanziell aus der krise
herauszukommen ehrlich gesagt ist mir
das noch gar nicht klar wie das aussehen
kann und welche um welche volumina ist
da gehen wird wir werden auch dann
sicherlich gerade die großen kapitalien
für investitionen brauchen also das dann
glaube ich sollte man jetzt erstmal
abwarten wie sowieso man sehr vorsichtig
sein muss bei prognosen einerseits und
auch den daraus abzuleitenden therapie
vorschlägen was die wirtschaft angeht
aber ich möchte noch mal auf diesen
punkt kommen mit dem altern nummer
grundsätzlich was das sparen angeht das
stattgefunden hat und die die notlagen
in die das gesundheitswesen insbesondere
geraten sind das ist alles richtig
ich glaube was wir jetzt tatsächlich
erleben und eben auf die schmerzen sehr
schmerzhafte tour ist wie wir lernen
unsere ziele neu zu definieren also das
was wir erreichen wollen als einzelne
aber eben auch als gemeinwesen dass man
versucht innerhalb der kollektiven
systeme effizient zu wirtschaften und
eben nicht unnötig geld ausgibt wo es
nicht erforderlich ist das ist
selbstverständlich und das waren
erstens die bemühungen der vergangenen
jahre dass man aber die ziele dessen was
eine gesellschaft vorhalten muss an
gesundheitsinfrastruktur und von mir aus
auch anderen infrastrukturen dass die zu
niedrig angesetzt waren
das wird uns jetzt klar und das müssen
wir neu definieren
ich glaube das werden wir auch auf einem
anderen niveau erleben in bei einem
anderen thema und das ist die frage
nicht wie weit soll unsere
wirtschaftliche verflechtungen in der
welt gehen aber wann ist es unvorsichtig
für unsere eigene existenz uns abhängig
zu machen von anderen lieferanten die im
grunde nachher in so eine art monopol
macht oder zumindest populistische macht
kommen gegenüber unseren
produktionsverfahren einfach aus
klugheit weder aus strategie noch auf
rang oder sonst irgendetwas sondern
einfach nur aus klugheit ich glaube da
haben wir etwas gelernt und darauf
wiederum dann aber wenn das ziel neu
definiert ist ein effizienz gedanken
also wenn es auch wieder nicht falsch
wir wollen ja nichts verschwenden wir
wollen nur mit den mitteln und unseren
kräften zu haushalten dass das beste
raus kommt und was das beste ist lernen
wir eben gerade eben noch mal nach und
da gilt es nämlich darum jetzt auch um
herauszufinden wie wir vielleicht die
globalisierung neu denken müssen
ich würde gerne auch noch einmal
wirklich zur frage kommen welches
staatswesen war eigentlich adäquat
vorbereitet weil dazu gibt es im moment
auch ganz viele fragen viele
diskussionen
es gab in ersten reaktionen so eine
mischung aus grusel und faszination über
das autoritäre durchgreifen des
chinesischen staatsapparates man hat
dass man hat sich die augen gerieben und
zugleich eben auch zum teil gesagt na ja
die haben die krise dann doch relativ
schnell überwinden können
die haben mit maßnahmen durchgegriffen
die bei uns nie und nimmer denkbar wären
wir schauen uns dort zu kurz ein papier
zum herkunftsland des corona virus nach
china region bay statt
hier wurde die epidemie unterdessen
gestoppt das resultat von zwei monaten
komischer maßnahmen von den behörden mit
aller härte durchgesetzt
[Musik]
jänner war sehr drastisch sie haben
gezeigt dass wir aus kann eingedämmt
werden
in den meisten ländern könnten solche
maßnahmen nicht umgesetzt werden sein
haus so viel man in der woche verlassen
würde bei einer ständig hätte weg droht
uns auch ein bio politischer
überwachungsstaat in diesem sinne weil
die volksrepublik china eine diktatur
ist eine totalitäre diktatur hat sie ja
auch die ersten warnzeichen schlicht
unterdrückt und da gab es den berühmt
gewordenen 18 uhr an der wand und der
dafür sanktioniert wurde bestraft wurde
die repression ereilte ihn und am
schluss ist er gestorben
ich glaube überhaupt nicht an die
effizienz von diktaturen diese
vorstellung in einer modernen komplexen
welt von oben herab
ein ganzes gemeinwesen führen zu können
das kann vielleicht kurzfristig ein paar
tage lang in einer katastrophe werden
aber das autoritäre das ist per
definitionem fast ineffizient in den
allermeisten fällen und umso wichtiger
scheint es mir dass wir und ich knüpfe
an das was karin horn vorhersagte an
unser bild des staates auch ein bisschen
revidieren was war der ideologische
diskurs der vergangenen drei vier
jahrzehnte staatsgeschenk staatsgeschenk
weniger staat bedeutet mehr freiheit
behauptete beispielsweise die
schweizerische fdp und plötzlich
entdecken wir einen ziemlich effizienten
start und rückt in den mittelpunkt ein
hoher beamter der die korona krise
gleichsam monitor irrt moderiert von dem
die meisten sagen er macht einen absolut
super job mit anderen worten die zeiten
da man sagte die wirtschaft ist
effizienz der staat ist ineffizient die
sollten endlich vorbei sein
wir beobachten große konzerne voller
ineffizienz und wir beobachten beamte
die die größte wirksamkeit und effizienz
an den tag legen hier ein nuanciertes
bild ein pragmatisches bild 1 und
ideologisches bild schluss mit dem
staatsgeschenk auf diesen start sind wir
ja in krisen angewiesen
und nicht nur in krisen sondern auch
nach der krise werden wir erst recht
sein
aber trotzdem glaube ich stellt sich im
moment die systemfrage noch einmal
zugespitzt ich meinen die liberalen
demokratien waren sowieso schon unter
druck schon vor der korona krise durch
autoritäre regimes durch reaktionäre
regimes da geht es ja auch in ihrem buch
darum eine antwort auf die autoritären
reaktionäre auch sie haben sich zu
diesem thema wiederholt geäußert das
heißt es gab dieses system diskussion
schon und die wird doch jetzt ein stück
weit schon zugespitzt ich meine zum
beispiel versucht man jetzt auch sich zu
überlegen ob man eine form dieses
kontakt racings wie es china eben
praktiziert hat übrigens auch südkorea
eine demokratie wo man davon etwas
übernehmen kann man überlegt sich
einfach zweckmäßige maßnahmen mit dieser
mit dieser infektion und der gefahr des
virus umzugehen und die ganzen
reaktionen in der öffentlichkeit haben
gezeigt dass eben genau diese art des
sehr invasiven racings bei uns nicht
akzeptabel ist und das schöne an unseren
gesellschaften ist dass wir relativ
schnell auch mit neuen lösungen und
neuen idee auf ideen aufwarten können
und eine dieser ideen ist eben ein
kontakt kontakt tracing über bluetooth
zu machen das eben anonymisiert ist das
eben nicht uns in einem big brother welt
zwangsläufig führt diese technologie
wird jetzt eben entsprechend entwickelt
und wird dann auf freiwilliger basis
möglicherweise
in allen ländern europas eingeführt
werden genau wenn ich ganz kurzem
ergänzen darf das wäre eine app die man
sich aufs handy lädt und die man auch
freiwillig nutzen kann und die daten
werden selbstverständlich wieder
gelöscht wenn die krise vorbei ist das
wäre sozusagen kontakt racing in
europäisch liberaler demokratischer
manier so wird das gemeint und das halte
ich für eine ausgesprochen kluge idee
also ich bin kein techniker und kann
insofern nicht beurteilen wie sicher ist
dann ist das sich nicht jemand irgendwie
noch zugang verschafft aber ich nehme an
genau darum geht es ist klar dass das zu
vermeiden ist dass das wird jetzt
entsprechend auf die beine gestellt und
außerdem werden wir immer in der lage
seien rechtliche vorschriften zu geben
zu setzen die eine anderweitige
verwendung nicht zulassen das finde ich
ist in ordnung also wie übrigens alle
maßnahmen die in dieser situation jetzt
ergriffen werden sofern sie nicht hat in
definiertem selbst sondern mit einer
bestimmten zeit der gültigkeit versehen
wenn ihr zweck klar definiert ist wenn
wir rechtsstaatliche ein hebungen von
dieser instrumente haben dann ist eine
ganze menge in ordnung aber es ist nicht
alles nötig was technisch überhaupt
machbar ist
da kommen wir in das themenfeld der
verhältnismäßigkeit und ich denke wir
müssen immer versuchen das
minimalinvasive zu senden
und was macht sie eigentlich beide so
glaube ich doch relativ hoffnungsfroh
dass in der schweiz zum beispiel jetzt
die gefahr nicht besteht dass ich sage
es jetzt trotzdem notstands regelungen
auch wenn das so nicht ausgetauscht wird
in der schweiz weiter angetrieben werden
sie selber haben das beispiel gebracht
in einem interview roger de weck das 19
39 die regeln die die schweiz damals
erlassen hat im zweiten weltkrieg wollte
die schweiz dann auch nicht einfach
wieder abgeben sondern es braucht eine
volksinitiative die verlangt vom
bundesrat die maßnahmen die ergriffen
worden sind wieder zu treffen war die
volksinitiative zur wiederherstellung
der direkten demokratie und ich stelle
mir nicht vor
beobachter ja auch die stimmung sowohl
in der bevölkerung
als auch im parlament die kleinere
kammer der ständerat der ja eine
initiative ergriffen hat
an die existenz und dann die
überwachungsfunktion des parlaments zu
erinnern
solche zustände werden ganz gewiss nicht
zurückkehren da der bundesrat einfach
autoritär weiter regieren möchte aber
etwas anderes beschäftigt mich und auch
hier sind wir mitten im digitalen
diese krise wird den digitalisierungs
schub noch massiv verstärken und wir
sind alle mittendrin mit unseren
konferenzen vor dem bildschirm und und
und das wird die macht der ganz großen
digital riesen google amazon facebook
apple und die anderen massiv mehren und
die hatten schon vor der krise viel zu
viel macht in wesentlichen teilen war es
nicht mehr der staat der die politischen
rahmenbedingungen setzte wie dass die
liberale ordnung vorsieht sondern sehr
viel entschiedener hat der verbund der
übermächtige verbund aus big data und
big money viele politische
rahmenbedingungen gesetzt und eine der
lehren aus der krise
aus meiner sicht wird sein müssen dass
man hier die demokratie so weit stärkt
dass sie ihre ureigene aufgabe nämlich
die rahmenbedingungen zu setzen dass sie
die wieder erfüllen kann
das bedingt den primat der politik über
die wirtschaft und das war etwas
ziemlich autoritäres was wir in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten erlebt haben
nicht nur die reaktionären populisten
haben den autoritarismus verkörpert
sondern auch konzerne die sich jetzt
immer noch über die politik hinwegsetzen
wenn beispielsweise credit suisse und
über es in der schweiz derzeit trotz
klare signale der öffentlichkeit und
klare signale auch der regierung und der
bankenaufsicht sagen wir zahlen die
dividende
wenn andere konzerne letztlich auf der
einen seite staatsgeld beantragen und
auf der anderen seite aber die dividende
weiter
zahlen wollen dann zeigt das ihren
autoritarismus und den werden wir uns
nach der krise wirklich noch mal sehr
genau anschauen müssen
und wir sehen da ja auch wiederum diese
schwierigkeit der globalen verflechtung
war das ist ein thema das haben sie auch
schon angesprochen wir sind natürlich
aus lokale demokratien global
eingebunden auch abhängig beispielsweise
bezüglich der versorgung jetzt mit
grundnahrungsmitteln was weiß ich immer
oder jetzt schutzmasken schutzanzügen
medikamenten
aber was sie ansprechen ist ja auch die
frage wie können wir eigentlich mit
unseren nationalen gesetzgebungen
transnationale globale mutis überwachen
die sehnsucht die das wird so wichtig
dass wir eine haben eine pandemie und in
europa haben wir das paneuropäische
verbindende zunächst zu beginn der krise
vergessen
nach und nach kommen jetzt endlich die
europäischen staaten wieder aufeinander
zu aber es ist der eindruck entstanden
italien das am schwersten getroffen war
wurde im stich gelassen
aber der erste reflex war der rückzug
auf eine nation bei einer globalen virus
verbreitung das war fast schon absurd
was aber doch die meisten menschen
wahrscheinlich richtig finden würden
also ich weiss nicht wenn man jetzt eine
umfrage der bevölkerung machen würde wie
gut ist natürlich findet man ist gut
wenn betten frei sind wenn man patienten
patientinnen aus mühelos aus italien
vielleicht ein fliegt und bei uns
behandelt aber die meisten haben
wahrscheinlich den eindruck ja jetzt ist
der staat gefragt und der soll erst mal
für seine bürgerinnen scheint
frau gleich was frankreich gemacht hat
nämlich die bewegungsfreiheit
einzuschränken war sehr viel gescheiter
als was deutschland gemacht hat nämlich
die grenzen zu schließen
und wenn man die bewegungsfreiheit
sämtlicher menschen egal welcher
nationalität einschränkt zu einer zeit
da man weiß wie explosionsartige
exponentiell das virus sich verbreiten
kann
dann trifft man eine effiziente maßnahme
die wesentlich mehr bewirkt als wenn man
die schlagbäume zumacht man muss das
natürlich in seiner entwicklung sehen
man hat die grenzen deswegen zugemacht
weil man meinte man kann erst mal noch
über die verfolgung einzelner personen
die das virus aus china mitgebracht
haben und dem dem tracing ihrer ihrer
netzwerke ist noch ein dem heißt das
dann klar war dass das nicht mehr geht
war die maßnahme selbstverständlich
insofern überflüssig als es dann darum
gegen leute zu hause zu halten soziale
kontakte insbesondere eben in größeren
gruppen insgesamt zu verhält zu
verhindern
insofern lässt hat sich ebenso
entwickelt ist wir sind hier alle in
einem gebiet wo alles unbekannt ist die
große unsicherheit die herrscht zwingt
uns alle dazu strategien auch anzupassen
das gilt für die politik das gilt aber
eben auch für die virologen und die
epidemiologen die dass die die beratend
tätig sind
dafür habe ich verständnis und das dass
politik an sätze sich unterscheiden hat
oftmals auch was damit zu tun dass man
einem unterschiedlichen punkt dieser
legendären kurve steht dass das finde
ich nicht das finde ich nicht so schlimm
was europa angeht dazu möchte ich doch
gerne noch was sagen ich finde nämlich
man ist so schnell damit bei der hand da
europa zu kritisieren und zu sagen da
zeigt sich mal wieder wie uneins die
mitgliedstaaten untereinander sind das
ganze hat nicht wirklich bestand wenn
wir auf die schweiz schauen da machen
wir uns jetzt etwas sorgen weil der
föderalismus eben eingehegt nur
eingeschränkt worden ist durch die
maßnahmen und der zentrale staat agiert
das findet in europa ebenso nicht statt
und das hat etwas damit zu tun dass das
ein staatenbund ist immer noch um kein
bundesstaat das sozusagen in dieser
notlage die sich lokal
weil bekämpfen lässt mit dem spiel was
ist es nämlich erst mal hat es eben
seine grenzen wie sie eben selber auch
ausgeführt mit denen mit denen mit den
ansteckung wirkungen wenn man das jetzt
doch eigentlich besetzte medizinische
wort dafür nehmen darf auf die nachbarn
man kann in der korona krise erst mal
sozusagen das heimische das lokale
versuchen in sicherheit zu bringen und
wenn das alle machen ist es auch ist es
auch gut und richtig so das ist eine
effiziente haben gehen sie brauchen
nicht unbedingt eine zentrale einheit
die das ganze steuert ich finde insofern
dass aus zweckmäßigkeit gründen gar
nicht so schlecht was mir auch nicht
gefallen hat waren diese überstürzten
maßnahmen anfangen die wirklich
unfreundlich waren wie das man
lieferungen nicht mehr über die grenze
liest dass auch die schweiz hat sehr
schnell zu gemacht was die italiener an
gegen das man worte ja verhindern dass
die sich im tessin nachher noch
behandeln lassen diese instinkte werden
natürlich wach das sind aber glaube ich
menschlicher instinkt in die sind
europäischen union nicht eigen sondern
das haben wir alles ein bisschen an uns
und es ist auch nur in der ersten
reaktion so gewesen die kooperation hat
danach wieder angesetzt
natürlich gibt es eine solidarität und
natürlich wird das auch auf politischer
ebene entsprechend verhandelt ich sehe
das überhaupt nicht pessimistisch ich
finde das solidarisch auf eu-ebene
momentan läuft ist von einer
größenordnung und einer bedeutung das
hat es noch nie gegeben und das ist sehr
schön vielleicht bevor wir einen schritt
weitergehen und auch darüber sprechen
was sie vielleicht lernen könnten
aus dieser krise würde ich gerne noch
einmal hören wie sie das einschätzen mit
blick auf die frage welches system wird
den profitieren sie haben mit werbe die
demokratie verteidigt und glauben auch
dass das was sieges modell sein wird sie
haben aber auch viktor orban erwähnt in
ungarn man kann auch nach israel blicken
netanyahu der überwachungsinstrumente
die normalerweise gegen den terrorismus
zum einsatz kommen jetzt benutzt um die
bürger und bürgerinnen zu überwachen
auch in großbritannien gibt es ansinnen
die sozusagen das momentum zu nutzen und
die die kräfte zu bündeln
eigentlich autoritär zu werden wie
schätzen sie ist ein müssen wir uns
sorgen machen dass die liberale
demokratie noch mehr unter druck gerät
sorgen machen es insoweit immer richtig
als es vorsichtig ist und wachsam macht
dass man verhindert was was kommen
könnte
mein eindruck ist dass die krise
akzentuiert was sowieso schon da war die
länder in diese die sich auf der kippe
befinden in richtung autoritarismus die
werden auf dem weg vorangehen
weil eben dieser notstand dieser
ausnahmezustand den potentaten die da
jetzt eben schon stark sind die
möglichkeit gibt noch mehr macht an sich
zu ziehen und die werden den teufel tun
und das wieder abflaut loslassen
wir werden mit ungarn noch viel ärger
haben aber sie haben auch andere länder
erwähnt wo das video das der fall ist es
gibt aber auf der anderen seite eben die
liberalen demokratien die die etabliert
sind die gefestigt sind wo ich sehr
sicher bin dass in der bevölkerung wenn
die krise einigermaßen wieder abebbt ein
unglaubliches bedürfnis hervorbrechen
wird eben erstens wieder mitzubestimmen
zweitens sich wieder bewegen zu dürfen
auch über grenzen hinweg bewegen zu
dürfen wie der wirtschaftens dürfen all
diese dinge die das verlangen nach
freiheit wird durch diese zeit der krise
und des spüren was es bedeutet die
bewegungsfreiheit nicht zu haben wieder
gestärkt sein und insofern bin ich da
wirklich optimistisch wir lernen gerade
was es heißt wenn wir das nicht haben
worauf wir schon fast gar nicht mehr so
stolz war wie es für selbstverständlich
hielten wie eben mobilität
wirtschaftsfreiheit persönliche freiheit
freiheit uns einfach physisch zu bewegen
in einer stadt all diese dinge die
mitbestimmungsmöglichkeiten die
fähigkeit parlamentarisch abzuwägen ob
wir eine bestimmte maßnahme gut finden
oder nicht
das fehlt und das werden wir doch wieder
haben wollen da bin ich ganz sicher sie
hätte werk haben auch war gesagt die
populisten glauben sie die haben moment
ganz schlechte karten also meine
zuversicht gründet darin dass die
demokratie und da gehe ich sehr mit
karin hahn einig die lernfähige
staatsform ist langsam weil der mensch
langsam denkt weil der mensch langsam
umdenkt und das spiegelt sich in der
langsamkeit der demokratie
aber sie lernt und evidenter weise
werden wir umlernen müssen nach der
krise zu meiner zuversicht trägt auch
beide umstand es zeigt sich in der krise
sehr gut regiert und wer schlecht
regiert und alle reaktionären populisten
ausnahmslos alle regieren ganz besonders
schlecht siehe trump und die katastrophe
die er jetzt da in usa vom zaum lässt
siehe boris johnson in großbritannien
der anfangs nichts tat und inzwischen
selbst den fokus der reaktionären
blätter die ihn bis jetzt immer gestützt
haben verloren hat ist all diese
autoritären populisten warum reagieren
sie dann ganz besonders schlecht warum
waren sie zu beginn der krise
die großen verdrängen und danach die
großen versorger weil sie kurzfristig
denken weil sie kurzfristig denken sie
wollen das was ihnen nicht ins konzept
passt nicht wahrhaben
beispielsweise haben sie deshalb auch
über jahre jetzt die klimakrise
geleugnet weil das ihnen nicht ins
konzept passt sie denken da braucht zum
starken wand denn offenbar muss es ja
auch noch ein mann sein und der regiert
durch und dieses durchregieren das
vermindert die komplexität der politik
in einer komplexen welt aber in der
gesundheitsfrage in der klimafrage da
ist politik verpflichtet auf komplexität
und diese leute scheitern und ich glaube
viele bürgerinnen und bürger werden
merken dass auf diese leute kein verlass
ist man sieht bereits dass die
alternative für deutschland die afd
bereits
in den umfragen massiv verloren hat nein
es ist die stunde der demokraten
diejenigen die an lösungen arbeiten auch
wenn es dauert ich wollte da nur noch
ein ganz kleines quäntchen pessimismus
doch wieder einsetzen obwohl ich
grundsätzlich so optimistisch bin aber
das ist die stunde der exekutive und das
bedeutet dass die exekutiven die
liberaldemokratische verfasst sind in
der lage sind jetzt auch möglichst gute
lösungen zu liefern
wir werden aber auch wahrscheinlich
erleben und wir sehen ist an denen an
den zustimmungsraten zu donald trump in
amerika dass auch diese exekutive
dummerweise zuspruch erhält einfach weil
sie macht hat weil sie sich inszeniert
und jemand wie diese populistischen
herrscher und und wie ein job in amerika
der seine macht ganz erheblich auf einem
imperium von fake news aufbaut
das wird ganz schwierig sein das zu
durchbrechen den menschen in der breite
überhaupt das zu vermitteln was sie
gerade seit nämlich dass er schlecht
regiert dass er in dieser krise versagt
ist also man wird man wird das ergebnis
sehen aber er wird immer noch jemanden
finden den er dafür verantwortlich
machen kann und diese diese spirale der
fitness zu durchbrechen wird noch sehr
schwierig sein
insofern weiß ich noch nicht ob das
wirklich sich sozusagen jetzt alles so
offenbaren und damit auch erleben ein
optimismus gründet darin dass zunächst
einmal joe biden zugelegt hat der
demokratische gegenkandidat für die
präsidentschaftswahl und mein optimismus
gründet darin dass die menschen auch in
usa die sind wie du und ich wie sie und
wir sie sind nicht dumm und sie werden
sehen wer gut regiert hat oder nicht die
macht der propaganda die kann eine
zeitlang sehr wohl wirken aber die
realität holt die propagandisten
meistens irgendwann früher oder später
ein
und dieser effekt der scheint mir auch
in den vereinigten staaten derzeit
einzutreten
da sind wir eigentlich jetzt bei der
frage was lernen wir aus der krise und
ziehe
die sorgen gerade wir lernen zb aus der
krise wieder die frage zu stellen dem
ist wirklich zu vertrauen wir lernen
vielleicht wieder demokratie
eine frage ist auch was lernen wir mit
blick auf die bewältigung anderer krisen
und die andere große krise unserer zeit
ist selbstverständlich die klimakrise
bei uns zu gast war vor einer woche
thoma bietet der ökonom aus frankreich
und wir haben ihn auch gefragt was aus
der krise aus der krone krise mit blick
auf bewältigung der klimakrise zu lernen
wäre man kann aus dieser
gesundheitskrise zumindest schon mal
lernen dass wir die regeln des
wirtschafts gebarens durchaus gemeinsam
fundamental ändern können wenn wir es
für notwendig erachten so wurde in
dieser gesundheitskrise beschlossen
einen großteil der
wirtschaftsaktivitäten und des
flugverkehrs einzustellen
das ist interessant wer noch vor ein
paar wochen oder monaten sagte man müsse
den flugverkehr und die co2 emissionen
reduzieren um die klimaziele des pariser
abkommen zu erreichen bekam zu hören das
wäre aufgrund der wirtschaft und der
kosten unmöglich plötzlich geht das bei
einer epidemie die zumindest bis heute
weit weniger tote gefordert hat als die
grippe oder umweltfaktoren in verbindung
mit schlechter luftqualität jedes jahr
zehntausende menschenleben kosten
dafür ändert man nichts an den
wirtschafts regeln für die
gesundheitsüberwachung sind extrem hoch
entwickelter warm und
interventionsmaßnahmen entwickelt worden
die manchmal vielleicht sogar zu weit
gehen die aber in ihrer gesamtheit wohl
gerechtfertigt sind
jetzt gilt es mechanismen zu den umwelt
und sozialen risiken wie der
ungleichheit zu entwickeln
die zwar langfristig ihre risiken sind
und nicht so plötzlich und heftig
auftauchen wie eine epidemie die aber
mindestens lang
ich ebenso notwendig sind ich hoffe also
dass wir diese krise entnehmen dass wir
kollektiv die wirtschaftskräfte
regulieren können und müssen
um ein soziales gleichgewicht für die
verletzlichen gesellschaften bewahren zu
können
in denen wir leben sie bietet die zu ich
würde die beiden krisen nicht
miteinander vergleichen wollen und uns
schon gar nicht mit der stossrichtung
die er dort wählt wir befinden uns in
der aktuellen der kroner krise in einem
zustand der wirklich ein ausnahmezustand
ist wo todesfälle uns vor der haustür
stehen also es ist sehr kurzfristig zu
denken und es ist auch etwas wo wir wie
ich vorhin schon sagte lokal handeln
können
das unterscheidet dieses phänomen massiv
von der klimakrise klimakatastrophe die
auf uns zukommt das ist einerseits nicht
gut weil es ist die langfristigkeit mit
der sie uns ins haus kommen wird dazu
führt dass wir es irgendwie auch immer
weiter aufschieben das ist das eine
problem das andere problem ist ein
trittbrettfahrer problem was die ganze
sache sehr sehr schwierig zu lösen macht
deswegen werden auch immer mal wieder
irgendwelche kompromisse geschlossen in
denen eigentlich nichts drinsteht weil
es schwierig ist für die regierungen
untereinander sich verpflichten
zuzubinden an vereinbarungen es ein
trittbrettfahrer und das haben wir in
der krone krise nicht so weil sie eben
mehr auch lokal einzugeben und zu
bekämpfen ist was mich am meisten stört
an seinen vorstellungen ist aber dass
die bekämpfung die er jetzt sieht dass
sie möglich ist durch die korea-krise
dass er die ja im grunde auf dauer
stellen will
also die korona krise zu bekämpfen mit
einem stillstand der ökonomien der
gesellschaftlichen interaktion und des
austausches überhaupt dass es eine
ausnahme die für uns sehr schwer zu
verkraften sein wird und das ist kein
zustand den wir dauerhaft haben wollen
um die klimafolgen zu bekämpfen wir
müssen was tun das ist völlig
wir brauchen dafür einen
handlungsfähigen staat der sich mit
anderen staaten einigen abstimmen kann
und die frage auf die wir uns
konzentrieren müssen ist eben wie können
wir dieses gefangenen dilemma die
tatsache dass wir uns nicht einigen uns
nicht gegenseitig so binden können dass
keiner einen anreiz hat daraus auch
wieder auszubrechen
wie können wir das lösen dazu gibt es
ansätze es ist schwierig aber ich denke
das ist keine auch der politische
prozess durch den man durch muss dass
wir zeit kosten das wird mühsam sein
aber der vorteil ist dass wir auch ein
bischen nicht viel aber ein bisschen
zeit auch haben hier in der korona krise
hat mir gar keine zeit da hier ist es
wirklich
wir müssen sofort handeln und dafür
geben wir temporär macht aus der hand
die gesundheitsfrage ist dringlich die
klimafrage ist dringend ich sehe eine
große verwandtschaft da haben wir eine
differenz zwischen den beiden krisen
zunächst einmal sie lassen sich beide
nur international wirklich effizient
angehen zum zweiten in beiden krisen
sollten wir bei aller kritik auf die
wissen schafft vertrauen
dieselben reaktionären populisten dient
der klimafrage die wissenschaftlich
gelten lassen setzen all ihre hoffnung
in die forscherinnen und forscher damit
sie jetzt ein medikament herstellen
damit sie jetzt impfstoff herstellen und
und und der raub war und den natürlichen
ressourcen
der läuft auf einen raubbau und der
gesellschaft auch an unsere gesundheit
hinaus läuft auch auf einen raubbau an
der demokratie wir brauchen künftig eine
öko demokratie die natur muss zur
teilnehmerin an der demokratie werden
dazu mache ich ja auch in meinem buch
genau zwölf ganz konkrete vorschläge
keine öko demokratie ist der kern dieses
buches oder ein
einer der wichtigen teile hier ja denn
wenn es uns misslingt den primat der
politik wieder herzustellen wird es uns
auch misslingen eine klima frage zu
lösen weil sie notwendigerweise mit
schwerwiegenden umbauten unseres
wirtschaftssystem ich sage nicht die
unternehmen ich sage wir alle sind ja
teil der wirtschaft schwerwiegenden
umbau und unsere vorfahren haben laufend
dann auch im 19
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
weiterentwicklung fortentwicklung der
demokratie debattiert modernisierungen
der demokratie fast seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg wird nicht groß über die
modernisierung der demokratie debattiert
und ich habe versucht einen kleinen
beitrag zu leisten um diese überfällige
debatte anzustoßen ein beispiel nur wir
haben in der amerikanischen regierung
das ist ein ganz bescheidenes beispiel
ein council of economic advisers 3
hochqualifizierte ökonominnen und
ökonomen und die sind teil der exekutive
die sind im weißen haus und die haben
früher zu ihren anfängen die
amerikanische wirtschaftspolitik kräftig
modernisiert warum nicht den den
westlichen regierungen ein kernziel auf
ecological advisors ein exekutive
umweltrat von einbezogen in die arbeit
der regierung der frühzeitig dafür
schaut das hier ökologischen nachhaltig
gearbeitet wird in den regierung und ein
ganz ehrgeiziger vorschlag etwas
visionär aber man muss ja die
diskussionen immer mal anstoßen
warum nicht früher oder später eine
umwelt kammer mit gewählten umwelt
abgeordneten die jeden gesetzentwurf
unter dem gesichtspunkt der
nachhaltigkeit der ökologie prüfen
würden in vielen ländern gibt es wie
selbstverständlich und das ist auch sehr
gut eine kammer der regionen in der
schweiz der ständerat in den vereinigten
staaten der senat in der bundesrepublik
der bundesrat
warum nicht auch eine umwelt kammer ich
denke in den nordischen fortschritts
freudigen demokratien die nur eine
parlamentskammer haben
das wäre entfernen man werde eine zweite
kammer einrichten eine umwelt kammer und
gerade für die jugendlichen die voerder
corona krise auf die straße gingen
riders for future und andere die setzen
auf die liberale demokratie
die wollen mit andy beraten demokratie
eine nachhaltige umweltpolitik alle
sagen ihnen ja ihr habt recht aber dann
werden sehr luftige klima pakete
geschnürt und wir stehen in der pflicht
diese junge generation die auf die
liberale demokratie setzt nicht zu
enttäuschen
und wir werden sie enttäuschen wenn wir
die demokratie nicht im sinne der
ökologie modernisieren
das war jetzt sozusagen ein fast eine
zusammenfassung dieses buches oder
wenigstens ein paar punkte haben sie
erwähnt jetzt zu dieser öko demokratie
sie haben zum beispiel auch den schönen
vorschlag der mich irgendwie fasziniert
hat einer fußabdruck bank wo man sein
eigenes kontingent an co2 emissionen
handeln kann wenn man nicht so viel
verbraucht sieht man was zurück firmen
können sich mehr einkaufen es gibt ein
ganze eine ganze palette an vorschlägen
wie die demokratie umgeformt werden
könnte um der klimakrise gerecht zu
werden
ich würde gerne aber noch einmal zu
picke die zurückkommen wenn ihr etwas
ein bisschen schnell gehen sein punkt
war ja auch dass viele leute immer sagen
der is no alternative es gibt keine
alternative das geht nicht also zum
beispiel den leuten beizubringen dass
man nicht so viel fliegen darf das geht
einfach nicht der flugverkehr nimmt zu
und nimmt zunimmt so dicke die sagt
jetzt guck doch mal es geht man macht
einfach die sachen dicht man könnte auch
vielleicht eine steuer erheben aber wir
haben möglichkeiten die menschen
umzuerziehen nein also erstmal geht es
nicht es stimmt nicht dass es geht es
geht gerade nicht wir sehen was ist mit
uns macht das wir nicht fliegen können
dass es überhaupt keinen zustand den wir
uns auf längere zeit wünschen sollten
natürlich können wir endlich mal das
kerosin besteuern natürlich könnten wir
die preise im flugverkehr aufgrund von
regulativen vorschriften hochfahren
um den leuten einen anreiz zu geben
selten dazu fliegen sicherlich das ist
alles möglich das war aber auch schon
vorher möglich also dass ist die frage
immer was was man politisch will und was
man für opportun hält
ich glaube das sind einfach leicht
totalitäre überlegungen an die ich nicht
gerne anknüpfen würde ich glaube dass
wir nach dieser krise tatsächlich von
selbst weniger fliegen wenn es jetzt ums
fliegen ging werden einfach deshalb weil
wir gelernt haben dass es auch möglich
sehen ist sich zu koordinieren ohne
immer über als physisch auch tatsächlich
präsenz da zu sein
also ich glaube wir werden unser
verhalten ein bisschen geändert haben
und das wird man auch schon mehr aber
frau horn
diese angst davor sagen wir es mal
wirklich totalitäre maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wie sie es gesagt haben die
verstehe ich extrem gut und das war ja
auch die diskussion am anfang kippen wir
ihn plötzlich irgendwie autoritäre ideen
wie wir im regiert werden wollen
regieren wollen
aber man sagt er doch immer wieder die
mittel die ergriffen werden um eine
krise und doch diese corona krise zu
bewältigen die müssen erforderlich
geeignet und zumutbar sein um die frage
was ist denn erforderlich geeignet und
zumutbar um die klimakrise zu bewältigen
und ein bisschen mehr phantasie hätte
man sich ja bis anhin schon gewünschten
und kommt hätte weg und macht ein ganzes
bündel an vorschlägen fantasie er ist
zwar in diesem buch am blühen man hat
viele ideen was man machen könnte und
die sorge glaube ich von vielen ist dass
wir den eindruck kriegen jetzt sehen
wird auch gewisse dinge wären möglich
bricht diese fantasie nicht in sich
zusammen wenn diese krise vorbei ist
ich glaube das nicht ich was ich erwarte
ist wenn wir dann hoffentlich bald sehen
dass wir aus dieser krise wieder
herauskommen wird es erstmal einen
aufholeffekt geben und den brauchen wir
auch ganz dringend und den werden wir
auch gerade deswegen brauchen weil wir
mit der klima thematik noch ein großes
thema auf der agenda haben wenn wir
wirtschaftlich um jahrzehnte
zurückgeworfen aus dieser krise kommen
dann werden wir uns das alles eine ganze
weile überhaupt nicht leisten können wir
werden kraftvoll sein müssen um eben das
klima in unserem prozesse hinein zu
bauen hineinzudenken
deswegen ist mir ihr gedanke mit der
kamera auch ein bisschen zu verspielt
ich glaube nicht dass man das braucht
was man braucht ist dass man wirklich in
jeder politischen entscheidung die
umwelt mit bedenkt und das sozusagen als
reflex verinnerlicht wie wir tun das mit
so also den vorschlag zum beispiel mit
der fußabdruck bank finde ich
sympathisch weil es ein bisschen
funktioniert wie die idee der
zertifikate man bindet man gibt der
umwelt einen preis man gibt dem klima
einen preis und baut den ein in das
tagtägliche kalkül der
wirtschaftstreibenden und wir sind alle
wirtschaftstreibenden jeder der
irgendwie seinen lebensunterhalt
verdient und geld ausgibt ist dass
dieses integrieren in das alltagsrad
viele ist das was wir brauchen und wir
brauchen das vielleicht viel stärker und
möglicherweise nehmen wir uns die mittel
wenn wir jetzt aus der krise folgen
genau so könnte es weitergehen so darf
es um gottes willen nicht vielleicht zum
schluss dieses teils noch hätte weg eine
frage wird sie hat es gesagt immer sein
wie bauen wir das ein wie bauen wir die
kosten nein das wird ja alles kosten
wenn man die gelbe westen denkt auch die
gab es ja mal noch nie haben sie schon
fast wieder vergessen
dann war das ja genau der aufschrei zu
sagen das lassen wir uns nicht bieten
wir wollen nicht einfach mehr bezahlen
für treibstoff sondern dann gehen wir
auf die straße
wie bringen sie die menschen dazu das zu
akzeptieren was sie wollen ich glaube
dass diese krise das bewusstsein durch
auch die debatten die wir uns für doch
jede debatte diese hier und tausend
andere debatten sind ja erkenntnis
orientiert wollen die menschen nicht
erzielen in keiner weise aber wollen
schlicht und einfach anstöße geben und
dann tauscht man sich untereinander aus
dank dieser krise gibt es unglaubliches
was macht eigentlich der reaktionär
donald trump in den vereinigten staaten
er führt während der krise fast so etwas
wie das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
ein leute die nicht mehr verdienen
kriegen geld und was für ihn undenkbar
war und dafür
viele viele menschen in der schweiz
würde ja darüber abgestimmt und diese
vorlage abgelehnt und denkbar war wird
plötzlich denkbar
was passiert im umdenken in
großbritannien boris johnson verkörpere
dieser konservativen die die britischen
bahn privatisiert haben
der übernimmt sämtliche defizite der ba
nährt praktisch zu beginn der krise die
bahn wieder verstaatlicht er wollte die
bbc der den inbegriff des guten
journalismus wollte er zerschlagen
jedenfalls wollte er dass man nicht mehr
maßnahmen fürchten muss wenn man die
gebühr nichts hat und plötzlich
verdoppelt die babys ihre ihre
zuschauerzahl und alle besinnen sich
darauf dass öffentliche medienhäuser
absolut unerlässlich sind
und und und vieles was vor der krise im
reaktionären diskurs dies abgelehnt
diskutiert wurde wird plötzlich denkbar
das ist die lernfähigkeit der demokratie
ist was ich so mag an der demokratie sie
setzt drei demokratische institutionen
in konkurrenz parlament regierung und
justiz und ständig gibt es ein
kräftemessen um die machtverteilung
zwischen den rhein
und sie setzt drei demokratische
grundwerte in konkurrenz freiheit
gleichheit und nachhaltigkeit und der
wert der nachhaltigkeit in der debatte
wird nach dieser krise beträchtlich
steigen auch wenn es immer mehr menschen
gibt die natürlich sagen das geht
zulasten der freiheit das geht zu lasten
der gleichheit
das ist der kern der liberalen debatte
dass man zwischen diesen drei worten
ringt und zwischen drei institutionen
ringt wohingegen autoritäre staatsformen
sagen so ist es und nicht anders und wir
werden lernen und diese bringen ist
sozusagen der kern der demokratie
ihr buch schließt ja auch mit einem
plädoyer dafür auf die junge generation
zu blicken ihr zuzuhören den freihof
usern und zu sagen ihr kriegt auch eure
stimme beispielsweise auch ein plädoyer
für ein
so ziert das stimmrechtsalter und damit
sind wir auch bei den kindern wir sind
bei den zukünftigen generationen
und tatsächlich wollen wir jetzt auch
noch wirklich den kindern eine stimme
geben wir von der sternstunde
philosophie haben nämlich gemeinsam mit
es meist cool einen philosophie
wettbewerb ausgeschrieben
kinder im alter von fünf bis 14 jahren
konnten malen basteln und schreiben uns
liebe kinder phase jetzt vor dem
bildschirm sitzt denn ich habe ja
verraten dass ihr den wettbewerb jetzt
gleich auflösen
ich muss euch erstmal sagen bossert und
ich wir sind überwältigt wir haben fast
300 einsendungen erhalten auf allen
ecken der schweiz sogar aus berlin und
potsdam und ihr habt uns begeistert mit
ihren originellen einfällen einen teil
davon könnte ab kommendem dienstag sehen
auf unserer website euch allen ganz
herzliche gratulation ihr seid
großartige junge philosophinnen und
junge philosophen jetzt aber zu den
gewinnerinnen und gewinnern ihr habt es
uns wirklich nicht leicht gemacht aber
leider mussten wir ja einen entscheid
fällen und ich beginne zuerst einmal mit
der kategorie der zehn- bis 14-jährigen
ihr habt texte geschrieben
zur frage gibt es die welt wirklich oder
findet die nur in unserem kopf statt und
auf dem dritten platz ist gelandet team
und stahl daraus warzen will er hat
einen kurzen aber glasklaren text
geschrieben
die nun du hast dich als platonische ihm
zu zeigen gewagt die idee war
wenn es in dieser welt blumen und bäume
gibt da muss jemand ja die idee von
blumen und bäume überhaupt erst gehabt
haben und deswegen gibt es auch die welt
das ist der dritte platz auf dem zweiten
platz
zu mehr jahren aus zürich die gegen ende
des textes zu idealistin geworden ist so
mehr ja du hast uns gezeigt dass die
welt möglicherweise nur aus gedanken
bestehen könnte und dazu hast du noch
eine fabelhafte zeichnung auch gleich
mit eingeschickt zweiter platz für dich
also auf dem ersten platz hellen auto
show aus bern
sie hat unsere fähigkeit zu zweifeln aus
anlass genommen um über die welt noch
einmal nachzudenken und hat ein
wunderbaren text verfasst über das
bewusstsein ein 14 jähriges mädchen das
durch einen text schreibt du musst
weitermachen mit der philosophie der
erste platz gehört dir ja ganz herzliche
gratulation und dann zur zweiten
kategorie nämlich die kategorie der
fünf- bis zehnjährigen die haben die
beste aller welten gezeichnet und da
wollen wir uns ein paar bilder anschauen
wir haben ein bild erhalten das bekommt
den dritten platz das ist von malin
baumgartner aus frutigen martin
baumgartner ist neun jahre alt und sie
malt eine wolke die alles böse einsaugt
rezitiert sozusagen roger de weck mäßig
die nachhaltigkeit mit eingebaut die
wolke sagt zum beispiel den corona kranz
vom kopf des mädchens und die korona
viren werden gemeinsam mit den waffen in
die tonne geschmissen umgewandelt in
energie um die wiese blüht danach mal in
baumgartner für dich gibt es den dritten
platz
dann hat nina moser aus gronau uns etwas
geschickt sie ist noch zehn sie hat
morgen geburtstag und wird elf jahre
haut wir gratulieren dir jetzt schon
ganz herzlich zum geburtstag nina du
bekommst den zweiten platz sie zeichnet
zwei hände die sich die hand reichen ein
mensch und die nachhaltigkeit roger de
weck wir sehen ist wasser feuer luft und
erde die vier elemente schütteln den
menschen die hand oder der mensch
schüttelt den elementen die hand
sozusagen die beste aller welten ist
eine nachhaltige welt und der erste
platz der geht an linus mühlebach aus
luzern ist zehn jahre alt und er hat die
stadt der gärten gezeichnet ein
unfassbares kunstwerk riesengroß mit
viel liebe zum detail
ich sage es mal so ganz kurz so groß ist
es geworden und wir hören linus auch
ganz kurz zu wir über diese zeichnung
berichtet
[Musik]
lieblingsbeschäftigung musik musik musik
spielt eine zeitung lesen
ja weil auch so unfassbar viel gebastelt
wurde vergeben wir auch einen
spezialpreis der sternstunde philosophie
für die schönste bastelarbeit die sehen
wir hier das müssen wir einfach ganz
kurz zeigen die bastelwelt der
achtjährigen dorothee räber aus
rosshäusern alles ist gratis arbeiten
ist freiwillig schule ist freiwillig um
das auto selbstverständlich ohne abgase
die süßigkeiten baumann vom himmel dass
hier noch der spezialpreis ja und zum
schluss selbstverständlicher meine
wunderbaren gäste hier im studio ganz
kurz frau horn die beste aller welten
was würden sie basteln
oh ja ich habe schon lange nicht mehr
wirklich gebastelt die beste aller
welten würde ich glaube ich ehrlich
zeichnen wie der gewinner auf platz eins
eben sehr bunt mit vielen menschen die
miteinander etwas unternehmen viel viel
natur
das würde mir gefallen da wäre ich auch
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das so schön
zeichnen könnte ich zweifel die
generation vor mir die 68er die wollten
die welt verbessern den philosophischen
kategorien job und sagt die jugend die
will das schlechte von der welt abwenden
den philosophischen kategorien amberg
das gefällt mir das ist realistisch und
pragmatisch ich danke ihnen ganz ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch und ich
danke natürlich auch den kindern für das
mitmachen beim wettbewerb vielen dank am
karfreitag hätten sich die sternstunden
den wiederaufbau der pariser notre dame
mit einem gespräch und einem film den
ich ihnen wärmstens empfehlen
am ostersonntag dann reden wir hier noch
einmal über corona und zwar darüber auf
die pandemie mit
unsere psyche macht ist boss hat fragt
zwei experten wie wir in diesen zeiten
das innere gleichgewicht nicht verlieren
und jetzt gleich in der sternstunde
kunst ein film über das match in ihrer
feier anlässlich seines 65 todestages
berühmt wurde er vor allem mit seinen
züchtigen madonnen bildern
er war aber auch ein pionier erotischer
kunst sehen sie selbst
danke fürs interesse bleiben sie gesund
und so munter wie möglich bis bald
[Musik]